[Music]  it's her 100th birthday  she was born in russia right during the  russian revolution  we had planned to have a big party for  her and then of course covet hit  and uh so i thought well what are we  going to do we can't do anything  my daughter kelly is the one that came  up with the idea of a drive-by  celebration another celebration  something's in the air she's been  counting down the days for probably the  last  three weeks since the beginning of the  month she every day she asks me  what day is it i tell her it's monday  and she says no no what's the date  very happy we were able to get a  proclamation from the mayor declared  january 21st as  nadia young day for her just knowing  that she's actually made it to 100  is i i think it's given her some  renewed hope in life